PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture,
we want to write down
the Feynman rules for QCD.
A lot of work happened
to get to this point.
If you recall, we derived
Feynman rules for toy theory,
then we extended this to
QED on the electrodynamics,
introducing and keeping track
of the spin of particles.
And now in QCD, We have to
do one step in addition.
We have to keep track of
the color of particles.
So color, the charge of QCD,
plays a very important role
here.
If we just investigate this
fundamental process here,
this fundamental
vertex, which is
very similar to a photon being
radiated from an electron.
Here, we have a gluon
being radiated from quarks.
And when this happens, the
quark changes its color.
So here you have a
quark with color blue
and a quark with color red.
The gluon adds a color.
It adds red, but it also
takes away the blue.
So the quark itself
basically carries two colors.
It's bi-colored-- one color and
at the same time an anti-color.
A leading order process
here has two vertices.
And this is a
scattering, for example,
of two quarks which
[INAUDIBLE] through a gluon.
All right, so we have
three kinds of charges,
meaning that the quarks
come in red, green, or blue.
So we have to keep track of this
when write down our amplitudes
or matrix element.
So we do this by just
introducing a new vector.
I call this c here.
Very simple-- a three-element
vector for those three colors.
All right, but how
about the gluon itself?
So QCD is based on a symmetry
group which is called SU3.
So it's basically a rotation
in three dimensional space.
There's eight independent
such rotations.
And what you want to
think about is just
moving from one color
state into the next.
So you can write them
down as I show here.
And we do this in
linear combination
of color and anti-color.
If you want to keep track of
this, we do this in this form.
We have a vector of A elements.
And the gluon is one
of those components.
This is given here for
this very first one.
So let me introduce
the notation here.
Literally, we were
introducing Pauli matrices,
but not for SU2, as a
symmetry group with SU3.
They're called the
Gell-Mann matrices,
and they're just written here.
Again, those are the rotations
I was just talking about.
Those are the rotation from
one color state into the next.
There's commutator
relations for this.
So if you have two of those
Gell-Mann matrices and you
tried to write down
the commutator,
you find this 2 times i times
this structure functions,
or structure
constants, times 1--
well, the next
Gell-Mann records.
So if you're just thinking
about how many combinations are
there, there's eight matrices.
We have 8 times 8
times 8 combinations
of those constants here.
And so it means that there
is 512 of those constants.
Most of them are 0.
And the ones which
are not 0, they're
listed here, or
combinations of those.
All right, so now we're ready to
just write down the QCD Feynman
rules.
Again, we start from
the external lines.
So for the incoming
quark or outgoing quark,
we write our spinor, and
then we keep track of color.
We do this for quarks and
we do this for anti-quarks
in the very same way.
For the gluon now, we have
to keep our polarization,
keep track of the
polarization of the gluon
and also of the color.
And those are the
vectors I just introduced
on the previous slide.
For the propagators, we
have quarks and anti-quarks
and gluons.
Gluons are massless,
so the propagator here
looks very much like
the one for the photon.
And the propagator
for the quarks
looks very much like the one
we had for the electron in QED.
The fundamental vertices,
I introduced one already,
but there's two more.
That's because gluon carries
charge and can come to itself.
We already discussed
this in a recitation.
So we have those self-couplings
of the gluon here.
And those vertices are as
relevant or more relevant
even than the one here.
All right, so the vertices
come with a vertex factor
in our Feynman rules.
Again, for this very first
one, we find a very similar one
as we had before.
You see here this
Gell-Mann matrix.
And let's just call this
a rotation in color.
But we have this three gluon
vertex and the four gluon
vertex as well.
And those come with
structure functions
here to keep track of the
permutations, commutations
between the color involved.
And it becomes more
complicated for this four gluon
vertex, which has pairs of
structure constants each.
All right, that's
all we need in order
to calculate matrix elements
or amplitudes for QCD.
The rest is just executing
the Feynman rules
as we did before for our toy
theory, and also for QED.